last week I received an audience
question a live caller I believe it was
asking whether I was going to cover
pizza gate pizza gate is this bogus
conspiracy theory perpetrated or at
least fueled given oxygen by the
conspiracy right
the Infowars Alex Jones etc also on
certain recesses of the internet which
I'm not even going to name in order to
give them avoid giving them more
publicity this is a bogus conspiracy
theory that alleges that a restaurant
called comet ping-pong in Northwest
Washington DC is tied to a child abuse
ring and this all started when John
Podesta's email account he was the
Clinton staffer was hacked and his
emails were published by WikiLeaks
during the presidential campaign and the
the it's a quite an involved conspiracy
theory actually Pat and it involves
child trafficking it involves various
different symbols on menus it's quite
involved isn't it yeah I mean it's
really out there especially considering
I'm sure Hillary Clinton and John
Podesta could come up with some less
controversial way to make money yeah and
one of the one of the aspects of this
that's pointed to is that there was
communication in John Podesta's email
with James Aleph antis who's the owner
of Comet ping-pong talking about a
fundraiser for Hillary Clinton okay so I
was not going to cover it after we got
the call last week I said I received a
lot of emails from viewers and I read
more about it and I said this is fake
news I'm not going to participate in the
fake news when it has not had any
real-world impact until now because a 28
year old man named Edgar Welch of North
Carolina actually showed up at comet
ping-pong over the weekend to conduct
what he described as a quote self
investigation of pizza gate he went into
the restaurant shortly before 3 p.m.
armed with an ar-15 assault style rifle
fired it at least once inside the
restaurant according to police people
inside the restaurant understandably
fled police locked down the area they
ordered patrons of a nearby they ordered
patrons of a nearby bookstore also to
evacuate I believe and it was the full
riot team right I mean we're talking
about SWAT here or something close to it
they apprehended the shooter edgar welch
and two additional firearms were found
one on welch and one in his vehicle that
was a Colt 38 handgun as well as a
shotgun in addition to the ar-15 rifle
that was allegedly discharged in the
restaurant Welch has been charged
assault with a dangerous weapon so far
is the only charge I've read about
police said fortunately no injuries and
James alef antis the owner of Comet
ping-pong said in a statement that this
really is going to be could be blamed on
the people spreading the bogus stories
about child abuse being run out of this
pizza shop and things haven't exactly
been great at the pizza shop it turns
out Pat since the story broke dozens of
threats against employees of Comet
ping-pong made via email via social
media this is nonsense from the fake
news recesses of the internet with
real-world repercussions that's the
takeaway and I told this story a couple
years ago about Glenn Beck and Glenn
Beck starting to rant about the tides
foundation and it actually led to a man
going to shoot up the tides foundation
and there's a term that applies here
called stochastic terrorism stochastic
terrorism means that when you have a
large enough platform mathematically
speaking if you talk about an evil or a
perpetrator or whatever there's a very
good chance that someone is going to be
inspired to take action in the real
world against that individual or
organization or location or whatever
because you're making a general message
about it
we can't specifically say Alex Jones is
responsible for what Edgar Welch did but
mathematically because of the size of
Alex Jones his audience it wasn't hard
to predict that someone was going to
take action and that's what we call
stochastic terrorism and I think it
really applies here yeah I think it also
goes to the fact that right-wing
extremism is the biggest reason for
terrorism in this country yeah because
when you have people that are enraged
and actually believe this fake news that
Hillary Clinton and John Podesta were
involved in some sort of child
prostitution ring yep there they're
going to get angered for it and they
made me misinformed but that doesn't
matter in the
and this is the world of fake news a
shooter got me to talk about pizza gate
because the shooter said I am going to
go investigate this I I don't even
understand what the purpose of firing
that round inside of comet ping-pong was
the reports to say he went and armed he
was self investigating pizza gate and he
shot around we don't know what was he
shooting at someone fortunately he did
not actually strike anybody with with
the the firing of the gun but this is
very very scary stuff I saw an interview
on CNN earlier today with a father
father and husband who was in the
restaurant having having pizza and
playing ping pong as people do it caught
a ping pong that they're not there to
trade children in some kind of child
pedophilia ring they were just having
pizza and just absolutely horrifying and
it's it's amazing that this has now had
real-world repercussions and everybody
who's been pushing this obviously bogus
theory should really re-evaluate what it
is what impact it is that they're
spreading of this stuff on the Internet
is having because it led to someone
showing up with three weapons and firing
one of them absolutely insane I'm so
glad that movement watch's is sponsoring
today's program as you know I have and
love my movement watch but what I don't
love is holiday shopping including
standing in lines including parking at
the mall including the entire thing that
many of us know all too well and why not
just skip the lines right if you want to
give somebody a watch and you're going
to go to one of those department stores
if you want a nice looking watch you'll
probably end up paying four to five
hundred dollars whereas movement watches
start at just ninety five bucks and you
can shop online and have it sent to you
or to the gift recipient and you skip
the line and more importantly you skip
the four to five hundred dollar price
tag you can check out all of the watches
and get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to mV mt
watches dot-com slash Pakman now is the
time to step up your watch game or step
it up for someone
else and skip those holiday lines it's
just a nightmare go to em VMT watches
dot-com / Pakman that's PA que ma n